c'est ainsi h et celle des pas comme les
autres il porte le nom d'une polonaise
célèbre marie curie sklodowska mais ici
le tiers des résidents une quarantaine
sont d'origine ukrainienne
dans la grande salle la télévision n'a
pas de répit
polonais ils craignaient résidents et
employés sont unis dans l'épreuve 2
millions de cologne 1 2 million et demi
déjà
ça c'est vraiment quelque chose qui me
parlent appartient à une famille
mélanger
plus et craignait un peu moins
- polonais à 95 ans un jeune anthony
sean et immunodéprimées il ne put sortir
de sa chambre mais ses souvenirs lui
tiennent compagnie de bombardements tout
cela j'ai tout vécu chez paix
2009 a comme enfin quand les en oman
ont mangé de la vache alors
il a été prisonnier est mis au travail
forcé pendant deux ans en allemagne à la
fin de la deuxième guerre mondiale il
devient soldats pour les américains qui
l'ont libérée ils arrivent à montréal en
1951 jeter médecin un écrin tous les
amis habitent là bas mes parents
parents de mon mari elle même inquiète
pour ses proches marina siminovitch
soigne ce chikhi la guerre a réveillé
des souvenirs douloureux savoir que
c'est la guerre entre les craignez russe
mais c'est difficile pour nos résidents
par exemple certains ont connu la
deuxième guerre mondiale et que ça
ramène des souvenirs ont encore des
membres de la famille d'abord la
direction du sus de l'est de l'île de
montréal est sensible à n'est pas de
l'invasion russe dans cet établissement
et le climat de travail est vraiment
difficile parce qu'on doit prendre soin
de nos hôtes des résidents donc on doit
quand même continué et je suis fier de
mes employés parce qu'elle continue
travail même en pleurant il se donne ici
des leçons d'entr'aide et de patriotisme
c'est le sentiment très intense c'est
comme le stress la peur en même temps
l'espoir en même temps la fierté de
notre pays parce que maintenant
tellement comprendre qu'est ce que ça
veut dire les ukrainiens ce n'est pas
les russes la pologne a fait un geste
formidable
merci beaucoup polonais ils sont avec
nous
il charge le polonais
chicha si le craignait il faut lâcher le
prochain show bike la pologne très
lucide le jeune anthony chaîne préfère
parler de politique
plutôt que de douleur et de tristesse
naturellement
nous sommes ne sont pas aussi aussi
forte qu'elle réussit mais apparemment
le leur aussi et on eu de problème avec
nous ils sont pas capables nous mais qu
au genou ici anne louise despatie radio
canada montréal